attention if anyone is out there if
anyone is listening this is Mackenzie
Meritt the Meritt estate is under
attack cleaners have reached the
perimeter they've brought enough fuel to
burn this community to the
ground
[Music]
I'm glad you could make it Matt wouldn't
miss one of your secret benefits for the
world ma what's the cause this time free
clinic in Brooklyn they lost one of
their grants last year and we're trying
to help make up the shortfall why don't
you just cut them a check take the tax
break and call it a day you can afford
it that would solve the problem for this
one Clinic but it doesn't change the
policies that created the problem in the
first place oh Eminem you're adorable if
you think that these politicians will
stop austerity measures because they
like your
canipes it's not about the party it's
about the relationships forged at the
party it's amazing what you can get
people to agree to if they see you as a
person and not just another rich girl
trying to build her brand you have to be
in the room where it happens to
influence what happens exactly and I can
provide the
well it is one hell of a room Roaring
20s is a great theme some of these
Senators may have been original members
of the club your grandfather started if
I had that kind of Leverage I wouldn't
have to throw a
party McKenzie and Natalia have been
acquaintances since they were very young
both having grown up in wealthy families
they were exposed to similar experiences
and privileges however there is a very
clear difference between McKenzie and
Natalia McKenzie strives to be more than
just another rich kid she aspires to
create a positive impact on the World by
driving significant causes that can
bring meaningful change to the community
yet despite the differences they
continued to stay in contact over the
[Music]
years happy birthday thanks don't be sad
Eminem I'm not sad n really you're not
you're so brave Eminem I mean if both of
my parents died in an awful accident I'd
be devastated how did your parents die
that what are you talking about my
parents aren't dead oh that's right they
just don't give a about you that's
why they never visit they never visit
because they're busy my father is a very
important man and my mother is a
drunk happy birthday Eminem I hope you
like the presence the lawyers bought for
you through thick and thin they still
bothered to remind each other that they
were still there even if it was just to
berate them Natalia seems to have a
special place for McKenzie perhaps it
reminds her of of where she came from
she sees her as an equal who just took a
different path but at the same time
McKenzie has the potential to bring out
the absolute worst in Natalia so given
what was about to happen in the future
she couldn't let her be this way
Forever After the dollar flu was
released and the subsequent fall of
Society McKenzie would convert her home
the Merit State into a refugee
camp nice little setup you've got here
Eminem thanks Nat surprised you didn't
send one of your henchmen to check up on
us you don't send a stranger to check up
on Friends agreed um so why are you here
Eminem Mac I know we've had our
differences in the past but I would hope
that after all this time given the state
of well everything you could bury the
hatchet that won't work with me N I know
who you really are and I'm not falling
for whatever this scheme is I'm sorry
you feel that way I was just trying to
help a friend I'll see myself out I
think that's best I really am quite
impressed with everything you've built
here you were always a true
philanthropist putting the community
above your own personal safety I always
admir that about
you even with the world at the brink of
collapse McKenzie and Natalia's rocky
relationship carries on while Natalia
attempts to in her words bury the
hatchet McKenzie is more than aware of
what Natalia is capable of and that this
suggestion is something more Sinister
behind it
however this doesn't make McKenzie
completely heartless she would still
call her after she heard about what
happened to her brother
Felix I just wanted to say sorry about
Felix what do you know about Felix we
just heard that division agents took him
out in DC yes I know we haven't been on
the best of terms but I know what it's
like to lose family and I want you to
know that no matter what happened with
us in the past I'm here if you want to
talk that's very kind of you but
completely unnecessary I'm fine here
you're not fine your brother was just
killed there's no way you're fine stop
worrying about me Eminem they were my
orders we knew the risk this was
inevitable I'm fine what do you mean
they were my
orders did you have your brother killed
you and your wild imagination Nat did
you have the division kill your brother
you sound tired Eminem you should get
some rest have a nice glass of sheep's
milk tea let your community take care of
you for once
I mean what's the point in taking in all
those Strays if you don't let them take
care of you every once in a
while as well as McKenzie thought she
knew Natalia and what she was capable of
and that she was a very calculating and
manipulative individual it was this
interaction that really opened her eyes
to how dark Natalia really was Natalia
implied that she always knew Felix was
going to die from this mission in fact
she had planned on it she is showing
that she is not above sacrificing her
own brother for the cause McKenzie knows
how callous she can be but Natalia
simply brushes it aside and implies that
McKenzie is being
dramatic and then there is that last
line from Natalia let your community
take care of you for once I mean what's
the point in taking in all these Strays
if you don't let them take care of you
every once in a while could this be her
way of saying that she herself took an
astray Felix and she used him to serve a
purpose which would ultimately lead to
his death once she was done with
him however it was also this moment when
Natalia decided that she had seen enough
she was in a much different position to
when they were younger she is now the
CEO and founder of the Black Tusk the
largest organized military that is still
functioning in the country Natalia
wanted to show the power she now has but
rather than eliminating Mackenzie she
just wanted her to be put in her
place I really appreciate you checking
up on an old friend for me sure thing
all I need is a name McKenzie Meritt
like the ays yes she's running some sort
of a halfway house refugee camp out of
the family's estate yes she is sounds
like you don't need me to check up on
her I'd prefer if you'd personally
confirm her current condition and what
condition would you personally like me
to confirm compliant copy
that Hellfire or right is a high ranking
Commander within the cleaners yet he
obviously has some sort of working
relationship with Natalia and as we
would find out later on Kelvin McManus
too given that he is a part of the
cleaners it wasn't hard for him to
convince his crew that the Merit State
needed to be checked out given that
someone dropped the rumor of a potential
Outbreak on site and the first two
cleaners that came to mind were the
recently married love birds Martinez and
Johnson I promise to honor obey and
respect our Union from this day until my
last I promise to honor obey and respect
our Union from this day until my last I
will cherish the life we build together
I will cherish the life we build
together no matter what challenges we
may face we will face them together no
matter what challenges we may face we
will face them together you are my light
and my love you are my light and my love
and I love you with the fire of a
thousand Sons for all of my days and all
of our nights we will burn as
one
the mayit state yeah got a report of an
outbreak at the community I have to run
this past to wife of course your team I
wouldn't want to do anything to upset
that we're solid we're trying to get
pregnant so don't want to take any
unnecessary risks H that's great news
thanks with kener and his Eclipse
gone it feels like it's the
right time to get back to normal
absolutely but you know if we don't
learn from the past we are doomed to
repeated you don't think we should be
trying for a baby I think you'd feel a
lot better knowing you're bringing that
kid into a healthier World check on this
outbreak rumor with me and then you and
Martinez can go in that long overdue
honeymoon right would approach fellow
cleaners Martinez and Johnson to ask
them to assist with the cleansing of the
Merit estate uncertain at first Wright
would use the fact that they're trying
for a baby to convince them that this
last job would be necessary to provide a
safe environment for their child and
there after they could take some time
off and have that honeymoon they've been
needing who told right about the
outbreak he didn't say then how do we
know his source is credible Wright never
asks for anything he's quiet and he gets
a job done no matter what he ask for
backup on this one I trust that his
intels good we need to be more careful I
know I told him we were trying and he
promised to give us some extra
protection if we go along said he's got
some kids that'll protect us practice
kids like one of those robot dolls they
give you in school so you know if you're
ready to be a parent or
not something like that but a lot more
useful in case things go sideways well
I'm not pregnant yet and right is right
we want to bring our baby into a
healthier world if there's a new bug
going around the Merida estate we need
to eradicate it before it
spreads right any updates love birds are
on board and ready for for departure
excellent any provisions required for
your coming out party promise some extra
protection and only a certain wealthy
benefactor can provide access to me or
Cal easier to use Cal's connections less
messy and the the love birds will ask
fewer questions excellent Rogues working
with the cleaners nothing new nothing a
Miss nothing to see here exactly when
you're done at the estate bring her to
me you sure would be easier to
neutralize the threat easier sure but
I've never known you to step away from a
challenge right you must have been
really close to go to all this trouble
for your friend we go back a long way a
lot of history
there while cheeking in with Wright
Natalia confirms that he has this op
handled this is perfect for Natalia
because it means that the Black Tusk
aren't technically involved it will be
handled by the cleaners with a little
bit of support from Kelvin
mcminis so where is this protection you
promised us in the crate this better not
be a trick very funny shade Tech what
the hell am I supposed to do with that
huh congratulations agent identification
confirmed agent Johnson status Rogue how
the hell did you pull this one off right
PA to have friends like Conley God Rest
her soul well let's take these babies
out for a test
drive McKenzie since out a d call the
cleaners are attacking the Merit estate
we are moving our people to a secure
location at the estate but we can't hold
out
forever we need your help our security
teams are trying to buy us time but we
have children and injured we can't
Evacuate the
[Music]
estate please if anyone can hear this we
need help we can't fight the cleaners
we're just people agents if you're out
there please we need the
division the first sale of division
agents sent in have gone Mia so Kelo has
organized agent QD pistols and a merry
group of men to follow up on the
compound after being dropped off outside
the estate Gardens the agent search for
a way onto the grounds to secure the
site in the gardens the agents discover
that the cleaners have a Napal mortar on
top of this they're sporting a new type
of armor and fueling system it would
appear that these cleaners are not just
your run-of-the-mill street hostiles
they seem a little more Elite
after destroying the turrets and
clearing the area the agents find a gate
and move towards the
estate running through the building it
would seem that the cleaners for some
reason haven't started sanitizing the
area like they usually would but this is
good it means there is still time to
find and save Mackenzie and the other
civilians on site once in the courtyard
the Agents come across a large abandoned
fuel truck however as they move closer
it would seem that they've been led into
a trap the cleaner starts spilling out
from all dire c s it's clear that their
goal is to detonate the truck killing
the agents and completely clearing the
front of the
compound however once again the agents
proved too much the front gate was now
completely open for the agents to move
in and enter the estate sweeping through
room to room clearing all cleaners on
site the agents would soon hear McKenzie
over the air pieces they have taken
heavy losses but Mackenzie has managed
to move the remaining survivors to a
safe room after guiding the agents
through a secret entrance McKenzie warns
that someone is currently trying to
break into the
Vault pushing forward the agents would
meet up with a prominent hunter or
cleaner boss hybrid called W while his
entire body is covered in purple colored
fire labeled as grep flames which is
powerful enough to melt any incoming
projectiles QD pistols agents made short
work of them by manually activating the
room sprinkler system making him
vulnerable to incoming fire the agents
then move on to the Vault containing
Mackenzie and the survivors the vault
door was damaged in the attack so wasn't
able to be opened straight away but
Mackenzie is safe so before breaking
through and letting them free there are
still more cleaners on site that need to
be dealt with the agents push through to
cleanse the estate of all the
hostiles surfacing from the tunnels they
make their way out onto the lawn here
they are greeted by the love birds
Martinez and Johnson armed with shd gear
these two proved quite a challenge for
the agents and were probably the reason
that the earlier of agent sent and were
quickly overrun but after focusing down
their heavy spam of tech the agents were
eventually able to Corner them in place
with good communication healing and
targeted DPS the love birds would soon
be taken
out once cleared CER would organize a
medical team to land on site recover any
survivors and bring them back to
Haven so there are a few things to think
about with this incursion we have Wright
who is technically a cleaner and a part
of their crew but is obviously very
close to Natalia as well as Kelvin his
model in game shows him as being more of
a hunter than cleaner so there has
obviously been some previous
collaboration there and certainly opens
up the realm of how far the hunter
program spreads is he a hunter that is
simply stationed as part of the cleaners
is he a hunter at all he Sports their
gear and look but given how he was
talking to Natalia and the way he was
referencing Kelvin he seemed like
someone who has more of an equal
standing at a similar level to each of
them and saying that is this how the
hunter program works they may get their
direction from Kelvin but perhaps they
meant to be left to run themselves
autonomously regardless right certainly
has or had some Sway and this was shown
by the shd tech that he was able to get
from Calvin and just openly handed out
to the love
birds I'm not sure if R was special or
if this is how the hunters function but
this interaction has actually
reinvigorated my interests behind the
hunters there are perhaps little less
predictable than I'd
thought on another Point McKenzie and
Natalia's relationship was certainly
quite interesting it would be fair to
ask why Natalia didn't just order
McKenzie to be killed but they grew up
together in a way friend ofies sort of I
think to Natalia McKenzie represents
what she came from and reminds her of
what she was once like there is no one
else from her early past that is still
alive and I think she wants to hold on
to the one little thing that reminds her
of simpler times something that will
help her reflect on what she's doing now
given that We rescued her I hope we hear
more from Mackenzie she opens up a more
human and vulnerable side of Natalia
that we haven't really seen up until
now something random that a few of you
might find interesting is that McKenzie
Meritt is actually voiced by the
division narrative director herself
Lauren Stone honestly if I hadn't been
talking to her about it I certainly
wouldn't have picked
it before I end this video there are a
couple of people I must think a Mr Rogue
gold was actually kind enough to provide
me with all of the coms from the
incursion long before I was actually
able to play it I wasn't really sure if
I was ever going to be able to find a
group around my end of the world who
could assist especially with my schedule
but he no questions asked smashed them
out and sent them through to me very
quickly and I very much appreciate it
dude and then there is QD pistol and the
Delta Force Australia Clan I feel like
they kind of took me under their wing
while I would say that solo I'm probably
more than above average at this game
mainly due to stubbornness and time
spent when it comes to team play I have
the coordination of a wet paper towel
fortunately they seem to be able to work
with us and actually put the time into
teaching me all of the mechanics if
you're on PC and can work around the
Aussie time zone jump into qd's Discord
there straight up good people I'll have
a link in the
description I warn you though I spend a
bit of time in the voice coms
distracting people while they're trying
to run through but they haven't kicked
me out yet so maybe they like the
challenge on that note if you made it
this far you're obviously a sucker for
punishment but I thank you for watching
this took a lot longer to put together
than I'd planned but I'm glad I took the
extra time hopefully you enjoyed it and
extremist molus extreme
[Music]
[Applause]
remedia